this movie is like Apollo 13 meets
castaway stop making noise cat I was
doing a funny opening joke that no one
else is made sorry David Matt Damon is
brilliant in this film he's a man
surviving off his knowledge his
instincts he brings the character mark
Watney to life with such personality he
doesn't overdo the drama in the
performance someone whose solution
oriented and finds humor in troubled
situations no matter how much he's being
taken down he keeps on going and that's
a big theme of this movie his
persistence so you solved the problem
and then the film he grows potatoes at
one point he's like hey you like
potatoes how you like dem potatoes cuz
in Good Will Hunting serves apples
that's supporting cast every cast member
in this film is great at first I thought
it was like well known actors overload
but you see that everyone is perfectly
cast everyone's raving mad Shuba
tellegio for Kristen Wiig lens like good
comedic chops to this drama I thought by
now I'd want to like do stuff with her
but I Isis build them now I'm not
attracted her I really enjoyed the crew
that Matt Damon was a part of the crew
that abandoned him like how my mom
abandoned me to the Philippines when I
was three years old still got
abandonment issues from it thanks mom I
really like Jessica Chastain she is so
[ __ ] hot Jeff Daniels is very
effective he uh three prizes his role
from dumb and dumber yeah Donald Glover
is not Danny Glover and he brings great
comedic charm to the film the one
supporting actor that I'm not even a lot
of people talk about but he was probably
my favorite Sean Bean it's a very
different performance than we're used to
seeing of him but he's still very
believable basically no cast member in
this film was ever wasted except when
they were behind the scenes doing all
that Coke and drinking in
and LSD and meth they were all drugged
up on set the directing and
cinematography this film is a stylish
science fiction picture I walked out of
this film going what a wonderful piece
of fiction the great thing is it's all
fictitious but from beginning to end
it's very believable and it generates
that escapism feeling that we love from
great movies one thing I really
appreciate about it was that it could
have easily been a film that was
overblown with CGI but it was rather
toned down which made it more believable
the way Mars is captured looks great
it's not overblown with visuals but it's
very appealing to the eye Ridley Scott
has let me down one too many times in
the past like every time I heard his
name I was like hot it's not gonna suck
but this is one of his best films ever
next to Exodus gods and Kings body of
lies and Robin Hood each sequence was
perfectly shot you really get a sense of
the director understood his characters
you know how to capture suspense and
thrills and you really root for this
main character to survive like the way
the world is following this mission you
feel like you're a part of that world
where you're just like hearing about the
reports and looking at the news coverage
you're part of that audience you're part
of the audience within the movie the
right drew goddard strip is fantastic I
was intentional that cat was meant to go
across there at that time they told a
really gripping science fiction drama
what I love too is this movie made me
feel smart like it's a smart movie that
made me feel like I'm smart for being
able to follow along I never paid
attention in science class and movies
that explore like science fiction themes
I usually have a hard time truly keeping
up like films like interstellar and
granted I don't know much about science
but it seemed very believable to me very
creative this seemed rather plausible
all the things that Matt Damon's
character was doing so it features
complicated science that audience
members can follow along with and enjoy
one of the more important qualities to
the film is it's really funny that's
major kudos to the script and yes to
Matt Damon especially this easily could
have been a slow strong out drama they
went a different route with infusing
humor that's a
Rises you and it truly works murder
whoops when sequences on earth not on
Mars but on earth went on for too long
like I would sometimes feel like I want
to get back to Matt Damon can we cut
back to Matt Damon please but don't get
me wrong but scenes were good they were
fantastic but I felt like if we stayed
on the other character stories for like
15 plus minutes I was like okay let's go
back to Matt Damon also the way the
movie wraps up in his final moments I
didn't one hundred percent agree with
not that it was bad I just thought there
could have been a little bit more of a
different direction that would have had
more of a reward but regardless I still
have walked out of this movie with a big
smile on my face I thought it was
fantastic when we get straight to the
point here all in all I gotta say the
Martian got it Galactica Lee right
alright guys well thanks for tuning in
to my review if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope a where
if you're lucky enough ya might just be
able to get high in Paris cope with me
where it is the ultimate experience and
it makes periscope a lot funnier and
more entertaining and you fall asleep
earlier too you also get a little hungry
kind of get some paranoid racing
thoughts sativas man they really [ __ ] up
your mind racing thought sativas man
they really [ __ ] up your thoughts
indicas are better because it relax your
body more so if you want to smoke we eat
and watch on periscope with me and I
smoke some some weed indica